foreign
Carmichael welcome to my last post on
Telus talks business for the year it's
crazy that it's been a year already
December can be a really tough time for
a lot of entrepreneurs I know it's tough
business slows down you want things to
kick up and and be successful and you're
wondering what'll happen to all the
business
so what we're going to do is share some
of the best quotes we've put together
over the past year from all the famous
entrepreneurs that we've profiled that
hopefully will motivate you inspire you
give you some extra energy to put back
into your business and have an awesome
2013. hopefully if business is slowing
down for you in December you can use
this time as an opportunity to plan and
make 2013 the best year yet for your
business so here are the quotes and I'll
see you at the end
thank you
foreign
thank you for joining me for another
video this is the last one that we're
doing for the year I hope you've had an
awesome year and you've gotten some new
ideas and some new motivation from the
quotes that we've just shared if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below one last time this year and I'd
love to hear your thoughts if you want
to leave a comment under the video thank
you so much I hope you have an amazing
holiday break and we'll see you in 2013.
thank you